Chris
Turn.
Okay,
let's sophisticate our head office a
little bit. The guy is down and we'll
introduce the concept uh point of no
return. Okay, so his spine
is his axis of rotation.
So if I get
way over here. I'm very easily going to
lose my balance over on this side. Okay?
So, your weight
should be on this side of that spine.
Your your center of gravity this side of
the spine, never over. Okay? A lot of
times he'll try to get me to go over.
So, we're not going to do it. He has to
earn it. Okay? So if you're trying to be
heavy, you can't can't get so heavy
because it's going to get light. I'm
kind of here. So if he tries that same
move again, it's too much weight on this
side and get topped over. Okay. So let's
fix that.
[Music]
Sorry,
you can stand up.
Okay.
And uh let's pay attention to
um
what's a real danger and what's not a
real danger. Okay. So, Sean, you can do
your test.
Okay. as he's here and he squeezes
really hard, it doesn't really do
anything to me. My trachea, my veins and
arteries are not impacted by this, okay?
So, I don't have to emotionally start
freaking out.
This is not a very trained response,
okay? But it's a very common one. So, as
he's squeezing me, go ahead. I have to
learn to relax because if I start
tensing then it feels like crazy
Okay, let him squeeze it and I release.
Okay, that's going to be our first
thing. He's going to squeeze it and
you're going to release just like in
there. Okay, and you'll feel like you
you should feel two things. He gets
tired because he had he feels like I
should squeeze harder. Um, and you can
feel the fatigue cycle because all his
muscles are tensing and then you feel
like I feel a lot better now than when I
was tensing up to it. So, what you're
going to do is they're going to squeeze,
you're going to tense up and see how
uncomfortable, right? Tap out when that
happens. You're actually making the
pressure. And then on the next one,
they're going to squeeze and you're
going to do the release just like in
Zet. Okay. All right,
Chris.
One with tension and one with releasing.
[Music]
Then you switch rolls. One with tension
and one with releasing.
Tense all your muscles when you're
they're squeezing.
Then relax all your muscles when they're
squeezing.
Hello. How are you?
All right. So, just take your time. Get
wherever you want to go.
Okay.
Were you able to feel a difference as
the person being squeezed? Yes or no?
Anyone not? Okay. How about the person
squeezing? Were you able to feel a
difference when they were doing Okay, so
it's it seems uh
maybe like a setup or silliness, but
here I had the same exact
environmental conditions happening, but
I had two different experiences based on
how I've responded to them. Okay. And
that as we take that macrocosmically,
this is
I could live and I could experience the
world one way or can experience the
world in an entirely different way.
Okay. Um, one way sucked. One way wasn't
so bad at all. Okay. All right. myself.
Whatever we do, however we move, you
have to be relaxed because you're just
going to make everything worse and
everything seems like there's no place
to move. There's nothing to do from that
tension spot. Okay. All right. So, he's
going to get the headlock
and let's look where I can move. Okay.
My arms can move, my legs can move.
Where can't I move? So, I'm gonna go.
That's where it starts craving on me.
Got it.
I try to turn my head. Nope. I can't
turn my head there. Okay. Um, let's say
this arm. I just keep my back flat.
Can I move that arm? Nope. That brought
tension in there. Okay. So, here's our
discovery learning. He's going to do the
headlock.
I'm going to move till I'm making it
tighter. God. Okay. I'm going to turn my
head to the left. No, that wasn't it.
Staying flat on my back, I'm going to
try to pull my arm
up. Okay. And you'll see that's not the
end space. But
[Music]
what you're feeling is the Dong Yong
clash.
for switch off.
[Music]
That's a
Okay. So your your jogging on his
yonging is increasing the force value at
his contact point. Okay. Um so that's
not if you feel anything like that. If
you feel the force value increasing,
you're not moving into the institute.
Okay? No matter how relaxed you are,
eventually everything's going to tighten
on you. Okay? So, here he is back on.
This arm
is not helping me back here because
while he can't choke me, he can
certainly punch me in the face. You see?
So, I got to get this arm
somewhere. Let me shut over here,
but I can't do it when I'm flat.
So, I can move this way. You see? But if
I go too far, that's young. So, I'm
going to just move enough and I go in
where
he has those little water holes like the
river going down. And now my hands are
over here. So, I'm do it again.
He's there. I turn sideways and I go
around all his mass. And now my hands in
front of me. Okay,
let's try that. And while I'm teaching
this, you want to you should feel free
to walk around and see all the different
angles. Okay.
Turn slightly on your side and start to
bring that arm through all the little
cracks,
not forcing them.
Stay relaxed.
And watch your point of no return person
on top.
Bring your shoulders to onto your side.
Turn your head and your shoulders to
your right. There you go. Now bring that
arm, the right arm through underneath
that little triangle space between him
and you.
Find it.
Yes, there it is. Okay.
Watch the point of no return.
So you got to pay attention. Okay? And
this always happens.
So pay pay attention.
If I'm on this side,
so he can't flip me over. You see the
space?
I can get rid of that space. Stay there.
Still I can get rid of that space. But
now what happened?
Over under. Okay. So, I don't mind if we
keep it a little alive. If you feel that
there's no space, they're probably over
the point of no return. You just turn
them over that way. Okay? Does that make
sense? Otherwise, have good form. Keep
yourself on this side of the point of no
return. And he'll find that space by
turning onto his side and bring this arm
out. Okay. All right. Try it. Here we
go. Yes.
Put your feet put your knees up. There
you go. Turn on your side.
[Music]
That's it.
So much Sorry.
Very good.
Don't thank so much.
Don't push back. Calm down.
Stay relaxed. Remember, you have to stay
relaxed the whole time.
That's it.
You have to get off your back. You got
to get on your side more.
That's it.
Stay relaxed.
Tension is going to make you sticky.
And change.
Bring your knees up. Bring your feet
near your butt.
Bring your knees up. Feet near your
butt. That way you can turn.
Don't fight. There is a hole. There's
always a hole.
[Music]
If you feel they're going too far over,
just turn over and they'll go. Very
nice.
figure it out. So, watch what I do.
Okay.
I can't get my forearm. Go to this side.
I can't get my forearm in there. There's
no way. You see, I can't get my hand in
there. You understand? My hand cannot
get in there. So, I turn on my side and
I get my elbow. You see? And I get my
elbow there. And now my hand can get a
little deeper if I move out of the way.
And I'm just kind of wiggling this thing
in there.
There it is. When we're here and he
goes,
no, everything gets tight. The tension.
So, in this drill, I know it's
difficult, but you're going to stay
relaxed
and you're going to keep moving what can
be moved.
Okay,
we're just looking at ourselves
and the urge to push. Okay, so the odds
are against you so that we can observe
ourselves when we're doing this. Okay,
so try it again.
It might be your elbow, it might be your
wrist, it might go back and forth.
[Music]
Stay relax
when the frustration sits in. Release
and relax.
Observe yourself.
Your turn. Yeah.
Good.
Observe yourself. Release the tension.
Psychologically accept what's happening.
Couple more.
space.
Okay.
Now, let's move away from this
selfobservation and let's go to Marshall
question. What do you think about that?
You're going to get punched. You're
going to get punched in the face. Okay.
So, he he does his head lock. He's
getting his head lock. I never let that
arm get over there. Okay. Go back.
He's doing his head lock. I always keep
that arm here. Do you guys understand?
Okay.
So, our drill is going to be this. Now
we're just starting in SA. Okay. Now I'm
going to clear and come in like he not
yet and go to the headlock.
He has to make sure that arm gets there.
So this move
is like that. Okay. He got that arm
there. Make sense?
I don't care how you start. Start from
contact. Try to bridge. I'll try to pass
there to see how non-contested. And he
got the arm there. So, I'm just doing my
move. He got the arm. Okay. All right.
Let's try it. Go.
[Music]
You got to get the head off though,
right? You got to get it inside.
You got to watch the point over turn.
[Music]
We're in.
Go.
[Music]
then
I'll get I I
All All I'm doing, let's say I don't
know. Where do you Where do you Where do
you want to start? I don't care. I'm
going to do the headlock. Where do you
want to start? I'm just pushing. Okay.
So, he's pushing, right? If I go around,
I'm never going to get there.
So when he pushes, you see how I slipped
in it and then I got him. The other
thing you can't let happen is you can't
let me pull that arm outside like this.
Okay.
Here. You can't get yourself kissing
like that. It's even harder.
So you have to get into the frame. Make
sense? Okay.
It doesn't matter how we start. I'm
going to start on the outside. You see,
I I'll do the same thing. There it is
again. And then he didn't let me get
helmet and I have the head. Okay. Do you
guys see that? Okay.
It doesn't have to be fast.
Doesn't matter. You can start from the
grabs. You want to grab me. Okay. Same
thing.
Just pinch your nugget. Okay. You got
it. And you're in the end. Okay. But in
all cases, why would I I don't want to
start contesting. I'll go around
whatever it is to get the head up and
then he has to go in the in space to get
his frames. Okay. All right. Try it
again. Doesn't have to be fast, but
smooth is best.
[Music]
And if you think you need it, it'll get
you there.
I'm going to take grip secure.
[Music]
Watch the point of no return.
Watch her emotional unconscious tension.
Yep. So, too far. Point of no return.
Head lock. Secure your grip. Good.
Sec.
Watch the point of no return. Watch the
point of no return.
Okay.
Here we go.
So, I ended up here
with my hands in this frame position.
Not him holding that arm there.
Not him trapping it out there. I got
here. Okay. And again, I asked myself,
what can move? This can move. This can
move. I can move
about here. There's a lot of places I
can move. Okay.
So, what I'm going to do with his
weights on me.
Okay. I accept it. It's fine. I'm going
to frame and we're going to take that
elbow of the first day of energetics.
That same co elbow. I get it in place
and I can secure it with the other hand.
And now I'm not going to push him, but
he can't close on me
because that elbow is there.
This is supporting the wrist.
I just move up the circle
and you can see his posture is changing
forward. Very balanced. Don't let him
close on me. I'm going to start moving
this way. Posture change.
I might need and I probably could use
this push, but if I don't, I just get my
leg up there or a combination.
And now I use his head that way.
Watch what I'm doing.
Uh, let me pass a second.
Here's his balance. Stay there.
I got him like this.
And this is the outward kazushi. I don't
want to push him that way. And push it
in this way.
You see with the leg,
your urge
is going to want to be to push him away
from you, but you're going to feel it in
your neck. Okay. So, I move out of the
way. Got some balance. Get some hook.
And then this keeps going that way.
Off he goes. Take the bottom foot over
the top leg and pinch your knees by
extending
your legs
trap. And we'll come to this finger
lock.
All right, let's try it. Stay relaxed
even on this side. Okay, go
frame.
Move up the circle.
That's it.
Bottom foot crosses top ankle. Extend.
Pinch your knees together.
Fingers got to go the opposite way for
finger lock.
There you go. Cross your ankles.
Extend your legs. You got want to be
more on his uh jaw neck, not his cheek.
Good.
Cross your ankles.
[Applause]
Push with your palm heel a little more
and move a little more out of the way.
Push with your palm heel a little more.
Push on for your flexibility.
Bring your pelvis off the ground.
That's it. Extend your legs.
And finger locks go the opposite way the
fingers normally curl. So, put your
other hand Let's start over there. Let's
start over there.
Get your frames inside the headlock.
Both of them there. More. Get your elbow
more in front. Okay. I'm sorry. That
hand is out. That hand is out. All the
way out. There you go. And use your
right elbow to frame. Put your other Put
your right elbow There you go. Supported
at the wrist.
That's it. Move out of the way. You got
to move out of the way. You're just
pushing them into you. You got to move
to your right. Move your body out of the
way. There you go. There you go.
Good. Extend your legs into the fall.
All right.
[Music]
Right away, I get off my back and I
start moving him.
I don't curl my head.
My spine stays neutral and I move me.
That's all I need. If I need more
leverage for my flexibility, I'm not
going to push around. I'll push the jaw.
You think when I push the jaw, I'm not
going to push your spine. Feel that
difference? I just push be space on the
jaw. Then you can get that hook.
Here I am.
That's beyond.
There's the end. Go back.
We're here. You see his bicep? Is there
any opening there?
So don't try to come out there. Go to
the grips or in this case I went
underneath. I'm out.
I move him into this by extending my
legs.
Get whatever I have here. What technique
is that?
Got it. Go kill.
If you're going for the finger locks,
that's not going to do it. And he's
doing his wrist, but that's not doing
it. Finger locks go this way. You see?
Does that make sense? Okay,
let's try it.
Oh, feel that's getting tighter. That's
more pressure. Stop moving there. Move
somewhere else.
Get your arm across. Turn on to your
side first and onto your side. That's
it. And let's put this all the way over
here. That's it. Okay. Now stay on your
side and move your whole body over this
way. And that's where he falls. Okay.
Now bring your leg around his neck. If
you need more room, you can take this
and that'll push his jaw up. Reach it
down. So you get your leg over his head.
Now you can't come here where his arm
is, but you you can maybe come out the
bottom. So take this hand. Good.
Good. Extend your spine and pull this
off. Pull it off his grip. Extend your
spine. Nothing doing over there. You got
them with your legs.
Divine the wrist lock.
agree this lock. Got to secure the
elbow.
So let's look
more identifiable.
Go kill. You see
go kill the elbow has to be stabilized.
If the elbow's not stabilized,
this might stop there. You get it? So,
you don't care what happens because I'm
have this pressure here and then I
stay still. I'll figure it out. Lay
down.
Okay.
If I'm over here and I'm not controlling
that elbow, there's not going to be a
pin. Eio is I don't have any strength to
do that there. Okay. So, somewhere this
elbow has to be stabilized. I can keep
it straight.
I can take it onto the ground. I can
take it onto my body. Does that make
sense? Okay.
Try it again.
[Music]
No, thank you.
Turn on your side. Turn on your side
first. Turn on your side. Angela, turn
on your left side.
Now get your leg. Come out the inspace.
Either the grip or under the arm. Good.
Make sure the elbow is stabilized
against the wrist joint.
[Applause]
Stand. Don't push against the bicep.
Come on. Eio is not going to work. You
have to go to go.
Okay. Stop. We're not there yet. Stick
in this move.
All
right, stay partner.
Again, do you remember the preface? I'm
just trying to observe myself. Okay, so
I have a controlled environment in this
so that I'm more observable. So my is
just try a headlock. I'm not going to
counter all this stuff yet. Okay? But
I'm observing myself and I'm learning
what is his face feel like versus Yong's
face feel like. Okay? We also have the
added task of
we already addressed this. Um there's a
lot of stuff we're supposed to know from
iikido such as non-contestation
such as my but because it's all assumed
in the form and most of our training is
forms training we don't actually have
that skill because it was put in place
in the form. Okay. So right now what
we're seeing is I can't find go
because I didn't have to find it before.
it was found for me and I just follow
that model. Okay, you have to be able to
know that wherever this is, that's
focal.
All I got to do is stabilize that elbow.
Okay, make sense? Okay. Uh cuz what
we're seeing is you're you're no elbow
stabilization. We're going the other
way. We're doing EQ. The eco no one test
eco. Okay.
In real life, there's not enough thumb
torque that I can get that going. Go.
I can break that thing. Okay. So, do it
slow, but let us find a technique from
this weird inside out, upside down
positioning. Okay. All right. Let's try
it again.
And we're trading changing partners.
Changing partners.
Observing ourselves. Turn on to your
side.
You can't find go, you should find the
inverse, which would be a finger lock.
Come out the yin space. The bicep is not
a yin space.
Get your leg over the top.
Cross your ankles. Extend him away as
you move through the inspace. Find it.
Find it. Find it. Find the arm.
Find the go.
Use three hands. When we're trying to
break something, use your two hands.
fingers. Yes.
Stay relaxed. Release tension.
Practice skeptics.
You're out. You're off.
Where is it? There it is.
All right. I'll give you another one.
So, I'm trying this move.
I'm not flexible enough. I'll keep
moving. Me
and I'm on top.
So when I'm moving,
this bottom hip is being pushed on by
the mat.
You're going to want to do that.
Instead, you pick up and now you move
that hip.
What's the difference? This hip is the
full rotation. And I go that way.
There's no way to go that way.
This hip goes that way.
Okay, I move me. All right, we'll try
that one. Go. Take the first one as far
as you can. You're like, I'm just
getting crunched. I can't get my leg
there. Move the bottom hip out. Keep
rotating it around that circle. Okay.
Turn the bottom hip. There you go.
Turn the bottom hip. Pull the bottom hip
out. There you go.
Take the first one as far as you can go.
[Music]
All right. So, let's look at it again.
Remember how we would grab either
shorter than third Joe or half Joe? And
I said, why is that happening?
Familiarity. No,
it's a stressorous floss. That's where
you first grab it and then you stay
stuck on that.
So, I'm trying this move. I have my
frame.
Why does this get stuck there?
Because you're stuck on it. What did I
show you? You can do it.
Push this neck.
I'm not pushing his spine. That's his
weight. I go around it. I got how many
more inches? Three or four. Okay. You
see that? So, I'm trying trying
there.
Turn the bottom hip. Nope. Not the
bottom hip. I got to come up.
Bring the bottom hip down.
Okay. Try it.
[Music]
Then pull the bottom hip out.
Pull the bottom hip out. Yes. Turn it.
Turn it. There you go. That's it.
[Applause]
He's too upright now. He's too upright.
Frame.
Use your palm heel on his jaw hinge. Get
on your side. move up the circle as you
keep pushing his jaw hinge over.
You're now not pushing his jaw hinge
over. You change your angle.
Yes.
Then pull your hip out. You're in the
way of him falling. Make the bottom foot
out.
Stay there.
Get this foot on the ground and this hip
goes this way. Now he falls. Okay.
You're trying to turn into the yong
space.
No, no, no. You're pushing him right. Go
back.
Get on your side.
There it is. That's it.
Get on your side, not your back.
That's it.
[Music]
Move your bottom hip out and keep moving
up your circle. Move your bottom hip.
No, that's not it.
Then pull the bottom hip out. There you
go. Good. Very good.
Okay, watch.
So, watch what we're doing. Okay, you
got to move about here. He can't fall
cuz I'm underneath him. You see that?
So, I have to move out from under him.
What I'm going to do is take this bottom
hip,
get it out of the way. I'm not going to
try to turn into him. He's right there.
That's why he can't fall. So, I have to
move the bottom hip out of the way.
No push here. I know you smell it. Keep
moving around the circle
to the full yin space. Okay. So, I keep
turning the bottom hip and I keep the
circle going. Okay, try it again.
[Applause]
You guys can work out your whatever.
Okay,
twitch his jaw. Go around his neck
weight.
Turn your bottom hip and move up the
circle. Pull your bottom hip out
and move up the circle.
[Music]
You got to get belly down
by pulling the bottom hip out.
That's it. Andrew,
that's musling.
That's musling.
Get on your side. Get on your side. Pull
the bottom hip out. Turn belly down.
Turn belly down. Turn. Keep going.
Push to lengthen.
Don't push. You're there.
Move out from under onto your side.
You're fine. And then this hip comes
out. Turn. Move up a circle.
Okay. Go.
Belly down. Move up the circle.
I know you can smell it, but I want you
to do the y instead.
Go belly down and move up in circles.
Keep going up the circle. Bring your
knees up now. There you go. That's it.
Change partners.
Get on your side, Derek. Side.
Push in deep into the first technique.
Deeper. Go up the circle. Yes, that's
it.
On your side.
of the circle. Good.
Deep into the first technique.
Watch the point of no return there,
Ryan. Watch the point of no return.
Turn on your side.
Go for that jaw hinge and extend his
spine. Don't turn his head. Extend his
spine. Extend his spine. That's it.
Keep it extended as you're doing the
other stuff.
Good.
Okay.
I'm going to go here
and you feel the yong space.
So, tension dog.
You'll feel the yong space. Okay. Try
it. Go.
Remember, they're pushing.
[Music]
Nope. Two hand grab. Two hand grab.
Push.
Push. Straight. I straight. Okay.
Di spinal penetration. That's all we're
doing. Get to tension.
And And I And I don't do anything. I
move again.
I do the prescribed round and I spinal
penetrate.
You feel the yawn. You see,
I don't go like this.
Do you see that? When he hits the yawn,
I don't go like that.
I just do my job.
He feels the yawn. That's what we want
to feel. Okay. All right.
Okay, we're good. We're good.
[Music]
Okay, now let's go back. Observe observe
myself
when he hits the yawn.
Do I have an emotional reaction? And do
I start flexing everything? Okay. Now I
just here I experience the yawn.
Okay, I try.
[Music]
and be ready to reflect. What am I
feeling?
What's happening?
Okay.
What are we feeling? You don't you don't
have to sit. What are we feeling?
What?
Okay. When the guy person comes in and
the tension goes and
Okay. Not not a normal breathing
problem.
What else?
There's a desire to just push straight
back on. Exactly. To to push on it.
What's the effect of of pushing on it?
What's happening to your arms? Getting
pushed back. Sometimes they're getting
pushed back. So there's like this,
right?
Or the bend.
You see? Did you guys feel the bed?
Let's do the technique. Watch what
happens to your arm when you're
breathing.
No, just that part.
Come on. Come in.
[Music]
Does my arm go back? Does my elbow bend?
Okay, you guys feel it now? Feel it.
Okay.
What else is happening?
Okay. I can feel the like Okay.
What I want you to do now to contrast
that feeling is now I want the red light
again. Dominican and I want you to go
and you'll see how relaxed he can be.
Okay,
got it. So, you're you're going to
you're going to reconcile the yong clash
and you'll see I don't feel Okay,
try it. Got it. If you need to fall, use
the ball.
[Music]
Okay. Ready to feel that difference?
Okay. If you haven't
[Music]
Okay, now watch this one. Go back to I'm
I just do the prescribed grab and the
spinal penetration. You're going to hear
the yong yong clash. Okay, we already
know what's going to happen to our arm.
What happens to our stance? Let's watch
that now.
I didn't say come forward. Come in.
Just do the
[Music]
Okay. What? So what happens to our
stance? Gets compromised. It gets
compromised. Go back to the choreograph
reconciliation. Watch what happens to
your stance.
[Music]
So solid now.
Hey, do you guys see? All right. Okay.
Why wouldn't this be
a yong young class if I am just trying
to take him back the way he's coming in?
You get it? Now, if you watch if you
watch my technique, I'll do two
versions. I'll do what we were saying
and then you'll watch my technique. So,
version A,
version B.
Uh,
what's different?
One's a projection at that point and one
is trying to more details than that.
What's different? Seemed like the
background.
Okay. My stance didn't get compromised,
I would say. What's the tension level
difference? Tension. Your arms totally.
So watch watch watch my hand.
You see watch the other one.
You can see the tension all going
through here. Okay.
So yes, I'm internalizing it but it that
concentrically is still not reconciling
it. Okay. So remember I said
energetically form does not matter but
marginally form does matter. Okay. So,
what I'm gonna do here is as he's coming
in to touch, I move it move him
sideways. So, he's gonna come in
and I move it sideways.
I let him hit the arm, but I move it
just a little bit off that straight 180.
Okay. And watch where my steps are now.
L
[Music]
sideways.
You see how I'm doing that? Okay, try. I
didn't throw. I just reconciled that
first yang clash. If you fall, you fall.
But I'm not trying to throw him. Okay,
Chris.
Leave them on their arm.
Good.
All right, let's go to a lower
mechanics. Andrew,
that's where we're at. Right. Okay. He's
pushing forward. You see?
So he will gradually increase that
pressure till he's full of long and
spinal disment.
This is no different than anything we're
doing. If I feel as soon as I feel the
pressure, I start reconciling the
pressure. You got it? So we slowing
everything down. He's going to do it
gradually.
There it is.
Okay. My foot maneuvers. I don't care
how you start, but we have to go 90 to
the
to the angle of attack.
Okay. Try it. Okay. Ready?
[Music]
That's it.
Good. It's a little late now, right?
Your arm out a little behind you. Okay.
So,
He goes about a little late.
I don't use the arms. We don't need it.
It's not the throw's not in the arm.
Let me get in position. There's no force
right now. He starts to go forward.
That's when I turn. Okay. Watch what I
do, though. I'm not going to He comes
in. I'm not going like this.
I'm doing a triangle back in.
Out in.
Okay, try it.
Out behind him.
[Music]
Don't let your arm behind you.
Keep your arm in front of you.
Good. Come back a little more this way
on the tree. So now a little more that
way. Yep.
[Music]
Don't let the arm behind you.
Okay. Remember the phrase painting the
picture?
Don't I I I know I know his body's going
like this, goes like that and goes like
that. I know that. But my arm doesn't do
that.
You get it? My arm is here. I do that.
You see that? So my arm is here. He
presses.
You see the arm doesn't move. The arm
doesn't curl.
Okay. Try it.
All that curling, all that is all the
contestation is all the reactivity to
it. Yes. Yes.
[Music]
Good. Good.
Yes.
Hey, Carter.
Here
we go.
Okay. All right. We got to fix your hip
first. Chris. Chris.
Okay. Spinal displacement
is not with my shoulders.
spinal displacement is with my center of
gravity.
See that if I was aggressing on him
uh with strikes, my center of gravity
moves forward.
I don't leave my feet here.
Okay. I'm going to stand where he is
standing. You got that? So in this
drill,
he's not going to lean forward with his
head. The energy is going this way. Then
that's not when you do tension hug.
This gets pulled this
like this.
You get to decide how slow you want, how
fast you want to go. I only go with your
timing. You could go super slow and
you'll see
not bad balance at all, but he will lose
his balance. Okay.
Okay. Try it.
Practice your bravery again. You're
going to lose your balance.
Don't curve your arm. Move your body.
Don't curve your arm.
Don't let it go behind you. Just
[Music]
leave it. Leave it. Leave it long.
Leave it in front of you.
Okay, let's let's figure it out. What
are we feeling? Like, that's not
working. I'm not feeling that or I'm
feeling this instead. Okay, what are we
what are we doing? Some of us are
getting it. Some of us are holding on
the old stuff. Okay, let's figure out
why. What do we got? Stand back up.
What do we got? And I feel like when I
lean forward and I have more semblance
of control of what happens, but when I
when I walk through like this, then you
almost essentially me, not almost
essentially, you immediately have my
center and I can't I'm not choosing
anymore. This one I can kind of do
whatever I want to do. Yeah. So, let's
go back to how we got here and you'll
see
This this happens. Okay. So, I I'll
first explain it, then I'll give you a
discovery learning where you can
experience what I'm talking about on
your own. Okay? So, how we got here was
I want you to grab yadi and I want you
to spin displace and I don't want you to
yield. You remember that? And all of us
look like this. Do the technique. Do the
first part.
You see? Remember that? No one look like
this.
You see? You got that? Okay.
What happened? That's the question.
Okay,
let us go back to the choreographed UK.
Okay. But I want you to be the uk and
experience
how calming that is when you reconcile
the yong yang. Do you understand? Okay.
Try it. Yeah. You're what you and you're
observing your body mind in that
reconciliation.
[Music]
Got it. Okay, we'll watch
this. The drill now
and you're going to observe your body
mind as we go.
Heard her hold her breath. Did you hear
her hold her breath?
[Music]
Do the reconciling one. She my favorite.
All right.
[Music]
The drill.
You heard it. Hold his breath. Okay.
What would you guess? Why? Why the
difference?
It's unexpected.
And you can't get just you can't get why
is it unexpected? You losing control.
You lost control. Who's in control?
The Naga is in control. Got it. So when
we pick a reaction of as uk that now
makes no sense for the technique we're
working on. We're trying to get control
back. And that's my rule. Neither assist
nor resist.
Do the prescribed energy print and don't
die at the end. That's it. Okay, does
that make sense? If we were doing gi
and the guy felt that and he's trying to
lower, then would have the ability to go
there, I would don't want to train you
to try to bring something up that's
going down. That would be contestation.
Okay, this was the guys coming in. Okay,
so that's what has to do. what you can
do because I it is terrifying.
Okay?
And that's not the throw. That's just
the balance breaking. Do you understand
the throw you've seen the throw? This
base here, I won't do the top part, but
this base is going that way. His hand is
going that way and his center is being
projected back on the 12 line. You seen
that? That's hairy as We're not
going to get there probably. But you can
control
how much energy comes back at you by how
fast you go in. He can go slow.
We just did the technique. Okay, got it.
Don't start counting for control. All
right, try it again.
footwork.
Don't look.
Yeah.
Don't hook up.
[Music]
Don't hook on.
So, let's look at the hook.
Okay,
there's the hook. You see the hook?
Okay, here you have your long arm, but
you do your long arm straight ahead. You
see that? It's hooking him.
So, when he starts to push and I hook,
watch where his center goes. Plot his
center in a vertical plane. You
understand?
There's the hook. He starts to go.
He came this way.
Go.
All right. Where did he go? It went
forward. You see that? Do you guys see
that? Okay. So, that means his center of
gravity is being deconstructed from his
head. On the other one,
I'm pulling his center of gravity this
way. On this one, I'm letting it go
forward.
That way, he's going forward, but he's
falling backwards. Do you understand
that? And so, I don't ever feel his
weight. It's no different than kotesh
goes forward and then back. I'm just
doing it on his head. Okay? You do
kayesh like this and everyone comes this
way. Okay? So, don't hook.
Now ask the question then how do I make
him move that way? What do you think it
is?
Okay. And what's generating the adhesion
here? His initial inertia. His initial
inertia. He's he's he's pressing on
that. I use that to move him. You see
that? Okay. All right. Try it.
Got to get a center to come past you.
Resist
the
resistance.
[Music]
That's it.
Resist the hook. Just keep the pressure.
Right. the his his yong aspect. I keep
that yong aspect. This is what I when
you hear me say I equalize his yong
aspect. Okay? So, for example,
if I go under value, there's no
adhesion. He didn't come that way. If I
go over value, I'm now contesting. But
if I latch him, he gets stuck to me. Can
you see that? Now, can you feel feel
your skin go like that? Okay. So, wait
till you Here we go.
Yeah. Okay. So, got it. So, he's
trapped. He can't go anywhere. And this
is what I meant this morning when I say
Iikido Kihon is using the inertia, the
centrial energy, the centrial energy to
generate what close-range grappling is
trying to do with fulrams and leopards.
So now it's not that I'm trying to
leverage his head, his whole body. I
make the lever with the inertia going
forward.
Got it? And so watch my hand.
There's no tension in the arm. Okay. Try
it again.
Where'd you move into the end space?
[Music]
Good. That was it. That the louder part
was it.
Good.
[Music]
Uh, for go the throat. Don't do the
throw.
If they fall, they fall. That's
different. That's it.
Which way does your center go?
Pay attention. You're getting it. Which
way does your center go? Which way does
their center go?
It goes straight. It's where their
center goes. Remember, if their center
doesn't follow me, okay,
it's following you. You're on the other
side hooking them.
Instead, I'm trying to use the ledge.
I'm going to go off. Okay. Uh let's try
this. Let's do a smaller drill. Okay. So
we're here and my drill is just on the
first step. So he goes to press. What
did I do wrong?
So behind me I went under yong value.
Go
over yong value.
Just this foot. I don't care what
happens. You can do it
with the other foot. Don't do this row.
Just bring him this way. Make sure his
center
passes.
It's not that I turn.
Cuz now the angle didn't change in his
posture. I don't turn.
Okay. Just this part. Try it together.
Try this.
[Music]
That's it. Don't you got to get off his
jaw. Keep trying to put some sort of
ledge. Use use the pressure. He goes in
too late. Too light. He goes in.
Okay. Try it again.
Yes, that's it. That's all we're doing
right now. Keep your arm long
and you got to step out with this foot
out.
[Music]
Match the dog value.
Good. Start relaxing more.
Don't let it go behind you. That's not
what makes this center.
Don't let your arm go back. That'll be a
lower y value.
Don't hook.
Don't hook. Change.
Hey, Angelo, anytime you want to jump
into anything, it's all good.
Remember
[Music]
I demonstrated
Try to do it with that lead foot out to
the side. Lead foot. Yep.
Yep. Don't look.
Make sure center's going past you.
That's better.
[Music]
We're getting there.
So, what do you remember from Z?
What do you do?
Come on. Release. Stable base. Release.
Stable base. What's my spine doing?
spine's going up, right? What do you
remember from the energetics?
Does my hand, what's on the other side
of the contestation have anything to do
with the integrity of the contact point?
Nothing at all. All that flexion is
unconscious tension in your body from
the from the pressure. Stay relaxed.
Move your own body. This is this this
what I feel. So, we go back to your
quote. It feels like nothing.
This is supposed to feel like nothing
too. This is what this feels like.
There's no one there. My own weight of
my hands are doing exactly this thing.
Just here.
Okay. Feels like nothing. While we're
done, we're just doing this.
Don't go till I get there. And he
gradually goes.
That's it. Okay. All right.
We got to reduce the surrounding
tension.
We're not fighting. I'm doing energy
drills.
Center has to go forward.
So, you got to let it squeeze into you
first.
That's better. Hi. Hi.
You're undervalued.
You're looking.
Don't do the second.
[Applause]
Good. Very nice. Don't do the second
move. Just the first move.
That's it. Then we're get a base up.
Get a base.
Yeah. Don't put use the energy, not his
anatomy. Use the energy. You understand
the difference? Okay. Uh, another thing,
uh, we did this. You guys mentioned
stable base, right?
He's pushing and we mentioned stable
base. Push, push, push, push. We
mentioned stable base. We come up,
right? Stable base. You see that? That
energy goes down.
I have a stable w I'm into stable.
I don't go from here.
Not stable. Okay. I will move out of the
way so I don't trip him cuz I'm not
doing the throw. But I move the same
way.
Okay, try to reduce the steps because
the more steps we need, the further we
are from the technique. Techniques two
steps. So
here
he's pressing
and okay.
You got to get it center and come
forward.
That's better. Yes.
Press more. You have to be comfortable
with pressure.
You got to let her press more.
You got to let him press more so he
passes you.
Don't turn though.
[Music]
We're getting there. We're getting
there.
We're calming down, right? Everyone's
calming down.
Same drill. Don't hook them. Don't bend
your arm.
[Music]
Don't do the second move.
First move only.
You got behind you.
Tension. Feel yourself for tension.
Good.
You're going to step,
Andrew. You're going to step, right?
Yes. You didn't step that last time. And
before that, you did the second move.
Twice. We're brave farting cuz we're
tense. Yes.
Let his center pass you.
[Music]
Good.
Don't do the second move. I'm telling
you right now, don't do the second move
because that is not how we throw from
here. Okay? And because you're doing
that second move, it's jacking up your
first move. You're making the first move
fit to the second move that we're not
going to do. And it's screwing up your
first move. Okay? But just do the first
move. It's no different. I'm I'm here
and I'm in Tai Chi and I'm That's all.
That's it. And guess what you're going
to do again?
Same exact thing. You're going to do the
same thing. You get it? You're have
there no problems. Approximate that all
day. Do you understand? So that's this
is the same thing. Instead of touching
his forearms, I'm touching here. He
goes,
that's it. Okay, that's all I'm doing.
Nothing else. Go.
We're not fighting. We're not doing
tension on you.
Push straight. Push straight. Push
straight. Straight. You're pushing
towards him. Yeah. You would be
aggressing like this, right? How big do
the technique?
See how I'm going straight.
Go. I don't go like this. Okay. Try.
[Music]
Don't go back. Get under your arms.
That's it.
[Music]
Good. Relax the tension.
Center has to go past.
Yes.
[Music]
Don't go. Keep your arm straight. Use
the pressure of their inertia coming
forward. Don't do the second move.
That's it. That's it.
[Music]
How much effort does that take?
None. Okay. It takes no effort at all.
There's no effort at all. I want you to
do the second move now. Whatever you
think the second move is. Okay. And I
want you to see how all of a sudden that
takes more more insertion. Okay. Try it.
No X patterns for my people.
You're going to do the second move now.
Hey, did you feel the I got I have the
umpsome. Did you feel that? Okay,
there's something else that happens. Um,
and it's in those hip lock techniques.
There's balance is going in one
direction, right? As I tilt that spine
and when I crunch his spine anyway,
what happens to my line of gravity? So,
pay attention. I crunch it.
It's moving back under my basic support.
You see that we have to keep the spine
extending on the initial
kizushi pattern. So when we do
we're here. Don't ask for me. He he goes
forward and I go like that and I crunch
that spine. His legs get back under him.
We go. I keep his spine long.
That's how I want you to do this throw.
You are going to feel there's no entry,
right? You're going to feel this
that part. That part got heavy. Okay.
The kazushi is there as far as his spine
goes,
but that's heavy. You see? See how his
spine was going that way? It kept going
that way, but it got heavy. I want you
to feel the heaviness. Okay.
Keep their spine going the way it's
going. I did not enter. Everything is
done off that first step. There you go.
Don't answer.
disl
[Music]
I He goes I lengthen it.
Okay, that's all I'm doing.
[Music]
Okay. Okay. Try.
I don't want you to
just going to lengthen the spine.
Whoops. Okay. Go slower. Go slower.
Really slow.
There's no injury. I moved off.
Okay. Got it. Okay.
Don't enter.
[Music]
Bring your awareness back to the the
That's very very good. Thank you. You're
using his
not his leverage points. Okay. All
right.
Where does the O come from?
Because you're not moving into the in
space. Okay. So,
when he goes here, we're going to have
to act it out. Okay. And I have his
center going forward and his body is
going back here.
His inertia was going forward and you
lengthen his spine. That's where the ump
comes from. You see what I'm going to do
instead is the center is going forward.
I go ahead and walk my friend. I'm
moving in here.
The pressure on my arm does not change.
If I stay here,
pressure increases on my arm.
I move into the inspace.
Keeps the pressure the same on my arm.
I'm not throwing him. Yes, that's the X
pattern angle, but I'm not throwing him.
Okay. What I want you to do
is whatever this felt like to me it
feels like two palms. Keep it two palms.
Okay.
No, I'm moving to keep that contact. I'm
not moving to make his head move. Okay.
All right. Try it.
I'm moving me. I'm not moving him. I'm
moving me.
You moved him back.
Don't move him backwards.
Don't hook.
Let's try it again.
Can you tell me a passenger stop? Okay.
That's the drill. Okay, try it again.
Go around their energy. Thread the
needle.
Thread the needle.
[Music]
Move into the space.
Get your leg back. Don't take the arm
further.
[Music]
Don't try to bend.
Get behind him. Don't bend them
backwards. Don't bend them backwards.
Behind him. That's it. That's it. That's
the drill. You move you, not him. You
move you, not him.
behind
me. Yes.
Don't curse your arm.
[Music]
There it is.
Go around that neck. Go around the neck.
Pressure. Keep it the same.
X. Yes. Yes. No. You brought us X Y.
Okay. Leave it at X. Leave it at X.
Leave it at X. Move to keep it at X.
Good.
Leave it at X. So,
um
that whatever that pressure was,
whatever that was, remember
I'm not going to let it go. minus. And
I'm not going to shove this into me,
okay? But he can't come forward. You
see, I leave it where it is and I move
me.
And when I'm moving me, it stays at that
value.
Whatever this value was,
are you going to go? I give it 10.
Hence, there's no hump in my technique.
Never increases. Do you understand
what you guys are picturing
if you're going to push off that
contestation point, you're going to
throw in. So, you're like,
I like that part,
But that's contestation. You understand?
What I'm going to do is go around
everything. Come on, Sean. Right.
You see? So, I'll leave this part out
and you'll see the fall still happens.
You see? So, when this arm is going into
the hammer spiral, which way do you
think he's going?
down. You understand? It's not me
pushing him down. It's not me shoving
him down cuz he was going that way. I
turned his whole body and now I'm just
staying with it. I'm not pushing it
down. It's now going that way and I'm
now blend with it to keep his spine
long. You see that difference? So I'm
not going here
shoving this down. He already is falling
right there.
That move is not pushing on him. He's
going with him. Okay. So to get there, I
want you to understand
that first contact that you play, you go
here. Second one, don't shove. Move
around. So what am I moving around?
moving around that and I'm moving
through this in space.
That's the technique
right now. Okay. What would be wrong?
What would be wrong? He goes and I move
this.
That's push him in.
I'm here. Stay there. Keep this value.
Whatever that feels like to you, keep
it. Don't move into him.
Move where there's green in space.
Okay, that's it.
If you fall, you fall. But I'm not throw
enough.
[Music]
You increase the value on his head.
No.
No. Don't increase the value after that.
Right.
That's it.
Don't increase the value after that.
Discipline up. Don't increase the value.
Don't increase the value.
better.
[Music]
Don't increase the body.
It means your hand can't go into the
final part of the inward spiral. Don't
do that. Okay. Watch something else.
Okay, that's where he is in the He's
going to be there in the technique.
Okay, so that's my first engaging point.
He's pressing. I use that. Where do he
ends? Where does he end up? Did you see?
Pay attention. Mark where he is on my
arm. Don't look at my feet. Look at
where he is on my arm. Come over there.
You should feel it slide. Okay. Okay. So
there's he's starting to press.
You see it? What happened?
I let it slip through. Okay. I'm not
increasing the value. Is anything around
decrease?